from bloody proms to Ascension Palms
this year Easter Sunday falls on a
Wednesday because of all the spooky and
kooky Easter eggs in Netflix's Wednesday
spoilers ahead when fans watch the
series they'll surely first notice the
Wednesday opening credit theme to be
drastically different from previous
iterations but don't fret if you're
missing the theme the series makes two
references to the song shortly after
arriving at Nevermore Academy Wednesday
enlists the help of a local guy named
Tyler to give her a ride to the train
station in Burlington in a conversation
Tyler expresses how he perceives
Wednesday's disposition ain't nothing
scary you just kinda
cookie
I prefer spooky even if you're only a
casual Adams fan you'll pick this up as
a nod to the original theme song's
lyrics later when Wednesday follows a
series of Clues to the entrance of an
underground nightshades lair she solves
a series of Edgar Allan Poe riddles the
first letter of each answer spells out
snap twice Wednesday does so snapping
with the same Cadence as the snaps in
the theme song
[Music]
this spooky opening credits are actually
a cleverly arranged Montage of plot
elements from the show the first object
they show us is a typewriter an
important facet to the show's version of
Wednesday she sets aside daily writing
time and is busy writing a new book
about Viper de la muerta the next object
a Nightshade Society volume hints at her
discovery of a secret Club below the
academy then there's her signature cello
and butcher's knife items to suggest her
musical abilities and plenty of murder
on the way in this show thing also makes
an appearance crawling up a spiral
staircase emblazoned with Roman numerals
a black widow then creeps down a
spider's web in a glass window the
window references Xavier Thorpe's talent
for drawing art that comes alive while
the window indicates Wednesday's room in
the academy other images like a Venus
flytrap and a moon give broader clues
for what's ahead cleverly an image of a
teddy bear in a guillotine accompanies
Christina ricci's name a fun reference
to her favorite pastime in the 90s films
death death to the enemies of the people
of the Republic
fra Justice is served the most important
image comes in the form of a Barren tree
engulfed in flames Wednesday's classmate
Rowan discovers a Doomsday Prophecy in
which Wednesday and Jericho's founding
Pilgrim Joseph crackstone are consumed
by Flames beneath the tree in the show's
climactic finale the prophecy comes true
though not in a way everyone thinks
in episode 2 Nevermore students prepare
for the upcoming Edgar Allan Poe cup and
are tasked with painting their own
canoes in its team are painting black
cats on their canoe nearby Enid and
Wednesday discuss Rowan and his supposed
death during the conversation Enid
glances over her shoulder and calls to
another student
you'll go come on flare those whiskers
the pokeup droops for No One Yoko has
long slick black hair and wears a pair
of Windsor glasses which is fitting
considering her namesake Yoko Ono has
often worn a similar pair throughout her
career it's pretty much her signature
look say what you will about her impact
on the Beatles but Ono is one of the
most influential multimedia artists of
all time so it's not a surprising nod
several Easter eggs center around an
iconic arrow and apple gag in 1991's The
Adams Family Wednesday ties up her
brother Pugsley and puts an apple in his
mouth Wednesday whips out a crossbow and
pulls the trigger Wednesday first
references this moment in the opening
minutes of episode one attending Nancy
Reagan High School Pugsley Falls victim
to several classmates Who tie him up and
stuff him in a locker with an apple in
his mouth at Nevermore academy one of
the extracurricular activities happens
to be archery Wednesday scours the
grounds to get familiar with the layout
and comes across Xavier shooting a few
arrows at a Target before only live
targets she tosses an apple into the air
pulls back the rosin shoots and Nails it
dead on as part of her punishment for
nearly killing some students Wednesday
must attend therapy sessions twice a
week principal Larissa Weems drives
Wednesday to the initial session to make
sure she attends Wednesday sneaks out
Midway though of course but that's not
the small detail you likely missed on
the building outside side there's a sign
that reads Miller and Goff Realty it
would appear showrunners Miles Miller
and Alfred Goff slipped in this
reference to themselves and it requires
an Eagle Eye to catch it Wednesday has a
lot of love for Edgar Allan Poe's The
Raven there are the obvious references
such as Nevermore Academy referencing
the iconic Line quote The Raven
Nevermore and Morticia calls Wednesday a
raven while complimenting her Visions as
more potent and more powerful there's
also a reference to the Raven with the
school's dance being called a rave in
and a Poe statue has been wrecked in one
of the hallways in episode 2 the student
paints their own canoes for the PO cup
and each is based upon a classic Poe
short story Enid and Wednesday's team
reference the black cat while Bianca's
refers to the gold bug the other two
teams have designs based upon the Pit
and the Pendulum and The Cask of
Amontillado the teams row across to
Raven Island where they retrieve a flag
and then race back to the mainland
earlier in the episode Rowan who was
thought dead rip appears to everyone's
shock In This Moment Wednesday recites a
quote from Poe's short story the system
of Dr Tarr and Professor feather believe
nothing you hear and half of what you
see
upon arriving at Nevermore Academy
Wednesday Morticia and Gomez have a
sit-down chat with principal weeps where
Wednesday learns that she has been
assigned to her mother's old dorm
Ophelia Hall refresh my memory Ophelia
is the one who kills herself after being
driven mad by her family
correct Ophelia famously appears in
Shakespeare's Hamlet she is a noblewoman
of Denmark and a potential wife for
Hamlet the violent death of her father
following multiple bad decisions on his
part Hamlet's indifference and other
factors combine to push her over the
edge Wednesday being placed in the
Ophelia dorm carries thematic
significance to the story much like
Ophelia she feels the weight of family's
ambition squarely on her shoulders
Wednesday forever lives in her mother's
Shadow as hard as she tries to break
free oh look there's my mother smirking
at me ultimately Wednesday is actually
the antithesis of Ophelia a strong
resilient young woman who defines
society's archaic systems in episode 1
Xavier shares a story about how he and
Wednesday attended his Godmother's
funeral when they were just 10 years old
his godmother was good friends with
Wednesday's Grandmama in their 20s
cousin its ancestor also makes an
appearance when Uncle Fester pops up in
episode 7 he helps Wednesday track down
Nevermore founder Nathaniel Faulkner's
diary in which he documented every
Outcast Community all over the world it
turns out Iggy it was his right-hand man
and trained generations of nightshades
there's even a portrait of it covering
the Nightshade safe perhaps this is an
indication that if the series gets
another season we may see Cousin It In
addition to all the Edgar Allan Poe
references the series nods to the 1976
film Carrie while the upcoming Raven is
all the rage Wednesday can't be bothered
and instead plots to stake out the hide
secret lair in the woods but her plans
are curtailed after thing slips a note
to Tyler about wanting to go to the
dance one state can't possibly turn him
down when he shows up to her room so she
Dons a high style new dress and attends
the dance The Raven goes off without a
hitch until there's a big hitch a group
of normies didn't take too kindly to
their crack Stone Fountain being blown
up and vowed to retaliate through a bit
of horrifying trickery as everyone is
dancing inside the group pulls up with a
trucker tank full of red paint and hooks
the hose into the sprinkler system then
they let the rain pour which is made
even worse by the overall white
aesthetic of the dance finally Wednesday
directly references Carrie as she tastes
a bit of the red liquid they couldn't
even bring for real Pig's blood
Professor Thornhill teaches a course on
carnivorous plants she's also
responsible for welcoming new girl
students to Ophelia Hall and greets them
with a a carefully selected plant to
match their style and personality I try
to match the right flower to each of my
girls what did she pick for Wednesday a
Black Dahlia of course throughout the
season Thornhill frequently tends to a
Venus flytrap nothing could Encompass
her personality and role in the show
better Venus fly traps eat flies and
arachnids and its persistence for
catching prey is deadly the same can be
said for Thornhill who is revealed to
actually be Laurel gates in 1990 the
gates family were met with tragedy when
their son Garrett was killed the parents
died soon after and Laurel now an orphan
was sent overseas where she presumably
drowned but a body was never recovered
more than three decades later Laurel is
still on the hunt she uncovers Tyler's
ability to morph into a hide monster and
makes him her slave she demands he kills
various Nevermore students as well as
townsfolk to complete a ritual to
resurrect the town's founder Joseph
crackstone in every way she is a Venus
flytrap herself she ensnares people with
her charm and wit tucked behind thick
rimmed glasses and when she has someone
in her clutches she Springs her trap
clearly the plants aren't the only
carnivores in class today in episode 6
Wednesday is working on her novel when
Thornhill stops by to drop off a copy of
Mary Shelley's Frankenstein she's both
my literary hero and Nemesis Thornhill
presenting the book is both an admission
of guilt and an indication of what she's
been up to Frankenstein tells the story
of Victor Frankenstein and how he built
his monster from body parts Wednesday
discovers a basement full of body parts
in jars which Thornhill later uses in a
sadistic ritual to resurrect crackstone
once Thornhill recites a passage from
The Book of Shadows electricity feeds
into the jars and lights up the room
overhead lightning slashes across the
night sky and thunderous Roars shake the
room you half expect Thornhill to shout
it's alive it's alive if it wasn't clear
the momentous scene is a loose
adaptation of the iconic scene from the
1931 film Frankenstein directed by James
whale while Frankenstein's monster is
arguably a victim crackstone is probably
the villain in this story
[Music]
nope hold on back up yeah that guy's
definitely the villain in this story
[Music]